The next thing we will discuss is the
so called, Iron Law of Performance. For a large
part of this class we will be looking only
at the processor itself. So the processor time can
be expressed as the number of instructions per program
times the number of cycles we spent per instruction
times the clock cycle time. Or the number of
seconds per clock cycle. To understand why this is
CPU time, we can do the following. The number
of instructions per program. Let's say this the number of
instructions per program, times the cycles per instruction, times
the number of seconds we spend per cycle. And then
the cycle here, we can cross them out. The
instruction here, we can cross them out. Then we get
how many seconds per program, which is the CPU time.
So why do we want to think of processor time
in terms of instructions per program, cycles per instruction
and clock cycle time, instead of just measuring the overall
time? Well, because these three components allow us to think
about different aspects of the computer architecture and surrounding areas
that we can change. So the number of instructions
per program is generally affected by the algorithm we use,
and by the compiler we use. If we have a
better compiler it might result in a more efficient program
that needs fewer instructions to do the same thing.
And also our instruction set might affect how many instructions
we need to execute in a program. For example, if
we have very, very simple instructions, it might take more
of them to execute the same thing. The number
of cycles per instruction is also affected by the instruction
set. This time the simpler instructions might take fewer cycles
to do, but also our processor design can affect how
many cycles we need per instruction. We will
see several techniques that allow a processor design to
spend fewer cycles per instruction without changing the instruction
set. And finally, clock cycle time is also effected
by processor design. We can design a processor so
that it does very little per clock cycle, thus
spending less time per clock cycle. And also our
clock cycle time can be affected by circuit design.
If we have faster circuits, they will need less time
to do the same thing that needs to be done
in the clock cycle, and also by transistor physics, because
they allow us to build faster circuits. So really, computer
architecture will affect the instruction set. And here we have
a choice of having complex instructions, where we spend fewer
of them per program but takes more cycles to do
each, or we can have simpler instructions, where we have
more of them in a program, but we spend
fewer cycles per instruction. And also computer architecture is
affected by processor design. So in processor design we
have a choice of making a processor that has
very short clock cycle at the expense possibly of
spending more cycles per instruction. Or we can have
a processor that spends a lot of work in
a cycle, thus reducing the number of cycles it needs
per instruction. A good design, in terms of processor design, will balance
the two. A good design in an instruction set will balance the two.